i don't know i mean all we have are
stories about that
i have one story about bill clinton from
the late 90s some a scientist that i
know actually met with clinton had him
for five minutes at an event
he said i waited for my moment
uh they had a couple of things in common
they talked about and the
this guy
uh he led into ufos by by thanking him
for liberalizing the freedom of
information laws to some extent that at
that time made it a little bit easier
for people to do foia requests
and then and then he somehow gently
brought up the ufo question to clinton
and according to this man
who i believe
clinton said uh something to the effect
of yeah i'm sorry there's not much i can
do about that i wish i could do more
about that but my hands are tied
and that's saul clinton said apparently
so that
and you need to think about it like how
much can a u.s president
actually even do
really
i mean does anyone think that u.s
presidents are really actually elected
they're selected they're not elected
it's been the way for generations
you've got a very very tightly
controlled system there
and i
i just don't even donald trump who seems
to be an anomaly
trump is a definite anomaly absolutely
trump is as much of an anomaly
um maybe even more of an anomaly than
kennedy was kennedy kennedy i would say
before trump was the last president who
actually thought he was president
that's why they killed him
kennedy actually thought
i'm gonna
i'm gonna decapitate the cia which he
tried to do
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna print non-federal
reserve money
four billion dollars which i mean even
in 1963 was not going to make or break
but it was the beginning
uh
and you know
apparently in october of 1963
talked privately about pulling u.s out
of vietnam after he got reelected
another bad move kennedy
and also yes according to a november
11th memo from 1963 11 days before he
was killed
talked about
authorizing or
ordering the cia to cooperate
more with the soviet union on the matter
of ufos it's like good grief this guy
he was like murdered in an agatha
christie murder mystery it's like where
everyone's got a motive like there's so
many reasons that right the cabal
you know plus he's trying to take out
the mafia how dare he he got elected
man that takes such courage
you know they brought out the cemetery
vote for kennedy he should not have won
illinois whatever you think about nixon
and kennedy kennedy should have lost
illinois he should have lost the
election but he won because he had the
mob
so kennedy goes in there and he starts
pissing off everyone and they take them
out so then then for another
how many 40
almost 50 years right
every subsequent american president
knows
you don't screw with these people
they will take you down absolutely
then comes trump
out of nowhere
you got a republican
campaigning in south carolina in 2016
dishing out against the war in iraq
no republican ever did that how dare he
and he did it
he's republican doing ralph nader's old
gig in the 90s talking against
globalization that's something that the
liberals used to do
ralph nader remember nader in the late
90s like we're going to lose jobs
through
these trade deals with china nader said
this
on behalf of working-class people and in
the democratic party kicked them out
basically they didn't want anything to
do with them but he was doing it from
the left and then that whole thing
failed and then 20 years later guy does
it from the right
like people were shocked
and then he gets elected
i remember a week before that election
julian assange from his exile said trump
won't be allowed to be elected
and i think everyone thought that
i think everyone believed that
i mean obviously the establishment fix
was in for hillary that was
obvious to anyone with half a brain
right
i mean never in the history of american
media had you seen an onslaught against
one person that intent like you
are free not to like the guy he's a
trash talker he's a new york as a new
yorker i grew up with everyone i grew up
with talk like that the men and the
women the boys and the girls they all
talk like that so that didn't the the
language never offended me i mean it's
maybe unpresidential but that's his
style
what i found interesting about him was
geopolitics and his global politics i
mean what the reason trump had to be
taken out
frank honestly there's only one it's not
because he was a bad person not because
he's racist not sexist none of that
ridiculous nonsense
he got taken out because he dared to
oppose the two pillars
of american global policy which are
which you must never do
and that is
international that's empire
neoconservative empire the neocon thing
and globalization
can you never you cannot oppose that are
you kidding me
and he went out as a candidate and
opposed both of them
you know i would think it was chuck
schumer right after trump got elected
he's on with amy goodman of democracy
man now
right
and
and
schumer he's talking about trumpet and
and the cia and he says oh my god don't
take on the cio a cia they'll find six
ways till sunday to take you down
and of course amy goodman by this point
i mean she did not ask a single
follow-up question but like obviously
trump had the entire intelligence
establishment after him
he went against he cannot talk against
the wars now he ended up being
surrounded by a lot of the same people
that would have surrounded hillary you
know the same neo bloodthirsty neocons
so um his international policy wasn't
much different than what you would have
gotten with any of the others
he was a little less belligerent in the
middle east
that's for sure
hillary clinton would have started a
major war in syria and she actually
talked about it so she was going to
escalate all that uh and trump didn't do
that so that's to his credit i gotta say
but otherwise he was pretty bellicose
uh
but he did stick to his guns and
globalization
and you know protect the borders and all
that
so that's just unacceptable you cannot
do that so was he allowed in on the ufo
secret i think that's what you're asking
and
um i mean i don't know
i think
it's obvious that the guy was interested
in it
you know in the last year of his
presidency he made a number of
statements
don jr
talking to him and i think june of 2020
about this
he's asking his dad about roswell
you know trump trump is a guy who
was very friendly to alternative media
in the years prior to his candidacy so
um
he's a nephew of an fbi agent who raided
tesla's home after tesla died in 1943.
i got to think trump knew knows
some things that are very interesting
whether he was able to get a formal
briefing on this
that's a great question i wish i knew
the answer and i just do not